so as we begin in the United States
we're the founder of a far-right group
who's stormed the U.S capital in 2021
has been sentenced to 18 years in prison
the leader of the Oath Keepers Stuart
Rhodes is the first person from the
group to be charged over the January 6th
ride his sentence is the toughest yet in
the hundreds of cases related to the
attack Let's cross over to Island Fisher
straight away who's standing by for us
in Washington DC I said Alan tell us
more about this case
well it's certainly at the higher end of
the scale of what prosecutors were
hoping for they had asked the judge to
sentence Rhodes to 25 years and prison
the defense they were looking for time
served essentially 16 months and
allowing them to walk free now Rhodes
was allowed to speak during the
four-hour hearing which took place in
the courtroom just behind me he told the
judge that he felt he was a political
prisoner and his only crime was standing
up against those who were destroying the
country well the judge wasn't having any
of that he pointed out that there had
been a fair trial he'd been charged with
a criminal offense seditious conspiracy
which is essentially trying to violently
overthrow the government of the United
States and he said that Rhodes was an
ongoing threat to the United States now
his lawyers have come out and spoken in
the last hour or so they said that
Rhodes was very stoic about the the
sentence that he'd received but the idea
that he's a political prisoner of course
is something that chimes with things
that we've had from Republican members
of Congress they have suggested that
those who have been convicted of
offenses after January 6 2020 when mob
attacked the capital to try and stop Joe
Biden's certification as president are
indeed political prisoners and Donald
Trump who is running to win the White
House again and is likely at this stage
to be the Republican nominee has said
that if he gets back into the White
House then there will be pardons for all
of those involved in January the 6th so
even those including the likes of Stuart
Rhodes now at 10 years has been the
common sentence for seditious conspiracy
over the last decade or so so 18 New
Years shows that the judge really does
believe that Rhodes is a threat to the
Republic now he didn't enter the capital
on January the 6th but he was certainly
involved in riling people up and he
stashed some weapons in a hotel near the
capital so that when he was
communicating with those who were
actually inside if they felt the needed
those weapons and the time was right to
produce them then he would go to the
hotel and he would bring them to January
the 6th so it could have been much worse
than things turned out and we know that
with 18 years that is the longest
sentence so far handed down to anyone
convicted of an offense on January the
6th 2020.
Alan thanks for that Alan Fisher
reporting there from Washington DC